Animators love to slip their own little jokes
into the backgrounds of their movies.
But the folks at Pixar have taken things to
a new level, adding tons of hidden references
to their own past and future films into each
of their movies.
Here's a look at the best of the best.
Toy Story Stories
Woody makes a rousing speech in front of a
bookshelf in Toy Story.
If you examine the titles of the books on
the shelf very closely, you'll spot a few
familiar titles: The Adventures of Andre and
Wally B., Tin Toy, and Knick Knack are all
the titles of short films that Pixar produced
prior to Toy Story.
Don't Overlook That Carpet
There's a tense scene in Toy Story where Buzz
tries desperately to find an escape route
out of Sid's house, lest he join Sid’s collection
of misfit toys.
But what makes it extra terrifying to those
with an eagle eye is the fact that Sid's carpet
is the same design as what's in the Overlook
Hotel from the 1980 thriller The Shining.
The Lion King Is Everywhere
You'll have to squint to see it, but in A
Bug's Life, if you look very closely during
the scene of Flik soaking in the ambiance
of Bug City, you'll see just how far the phenomenon
of The Lion King's Broadway adaptation has
traveled.
Mrs. Potato Head's Reading Material
When Mr. Potato Head makes his appearance
in Toy Story 2, he pretty much steals the
show.
And Mrs. Potato Head agrees.
When she realizes that he's found her missing
earring, she immediately throws down the book
she's been reading: a storybook of A Bug's
Life.
A Nemo Preview
There are Easter eggs, and then there are
next-level Easter eggs.
You know the bit in Monsters, Inc. where Boo
hands Sully her stuffed Nemo?
Well, Finding Nemo didn't come out until two
years after Monsters, Inc.
It's all part of Pixar's master plan.
An Incredible Cameo
Pixar also snuck a sneak peak of a future
film into Finding Nemo itself.
If you look closely at the bit where the kid
in the dentist's office is scared senseless
by the sounds of Nemo's escape attempt, you'll
see that he's reading a Mr. Incredible comic
book—a full year and a half before The Incredibles
hit theaters.
Rex Isn't Extinct
Of all the things you'd expect to survive
our planet's self-induced ecological disaster
in Wall*E, you'd wouldn't predict that one
of Andy's toys from Toy Story would be on
that list of items, let alone the one that's
been extinct for millions of years.
Nonetheless, when we're given a look into
Wall*E's sanctuary and see all the junk contained
within its walls, there's Rex's toothy grin
smiling at you.
Postcard From The Fredricksens
As we know from the opening credits of Up,
Carl and Ellie Fredericksen traveled quite
a bit in their youth.
In the process, they apparently made a few
friendships that we've yet to see explored.
If you take a very close look at the bulletin
board in Andy's room in Toy Story 3, you'll
see that the Fredericksens sent Andy a postcard.
That's considerate of them.
Monster In The Woodwork
When Princess Merida takes it upon herself
to stroll through the forest, she finds herself
at the house of a witch.
Merida watches in awe as a magic broom moves
around the room on its own power.
But what's more fascinating is that its path
takes it—and the viewer—past a log which
has Sully from Monsters, Inc. carved into
it.
A113 Marks The Spot
You may already be aware of how "A113" has
a tendency to show up in just about every
film produced by Pixar.
It's shown up on a license plate in Toy Story,
a train in Cars, on a tag attached to Git
the rat's ear in Ratatouille, and in many,
many more places.
So what is A113?
Why not ask the man himself, Pixar's chief
creative officer John Lasseter.
“A113 was the animation, um, classroom at
California Institute of the Arts in the character
animation program
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Pixar Easter egg you like best…